[Applause]
thank you welcome welcome everyone
welcome welcome transfer students
visiting international students Eli
Whitney students and welcome first-year
students so happy to see you all after a
a fantastic move-in weekend you all
brought the best weather in many years
so I think are off to a great start to
your four years
did you enjoy Bulldog - we should do it
again next year okay yeah and really
hope you're all getting settled and
excited for the year ahead classes start
tomorrow morning and you know one thing
you're gonna find out about classes
around here is that is that you have
some time to pick what you're gonna take
we have this shopping period and and to
try out the courses you want to take
first and of course that's what I hope
you'll do it's a really exciting time a
little hectic but you know a lot of it's
about juggling a lot of the options and
choices great choices that you have as
you make up your minds but before we met
before any of that happens today this
afternoon we're gonna have this
opportunity to think in the broadest
sense about the intellectual community
that you're joining and to start
thinking about your own intellectual
life here at Yale some of you may have
planned out every semester for your
entire four years ahead down to every
class you will take while some of you
are just the opposite not knowing even
where to start and of course that's all
good and many of you are probably
somewhere in between with a general idea
of what your next move will be but with
an openness to new ideas so whatever you
have in mind
I hope this afternoon that you'll get a
sense of the world of ideas that's
awaiting you and there's also some
practical business today that we'll
attend to later on which is learning how
to sing right college years
and so with help from the glee club
which is with us here today
you'll get a chance to practice and then
by the time you leave this place you'll
be able to take your place besides Yale
students and alumni who know this song
inside and out and you have the lyrics
with you and as part of your program and
we'll come back to this after after our
speech so it's now my pleasure to
introduce our keynote speaker sarah
diemer's the Horace D Taft associate
professor of physics professor Demers is
an award-winning distinguished member of
the Yale faculty and an excellent
example of the intellectual
possibilities ahead of you after her
receiving her a be from Harvard
University professor Demers attended the
University of Rochester Harvard is a
good school and and so is University of
Rochester and where she was awarded her
MA and PhD in physics after teaching at
Roberts Wesleyan College and serving as
a research associate at Stanford's
linear accelerator Center professor
Demers joined the Yale faculty in 2009
as assistant professor of physics and in
the spring 2020 she will be singing
teaching a course at the nicely sing
she'll be teaching a course titled the
physics of music professor Demers
researches physics beyond the standard
model at CERN's Large Hadron Collider
and is currently studying Higgs boson
and Z boson decays she also works on the
trigger experiment for this study in
addition she leads the DeMars group at
Yale co-leads the Atlas upgrade physics
group becomes the elected chair of the
US Atlas Institute board in January and
is a member of the MU to e collaboration
at Fermilab professor Demers is the
co-founder of the Yale Frankie and
Whitney humanity Center group
interdisciplinary Arts & Science
Research with associate professor of
theatre studies and director of the
dance studies curriculum
Emily Coates she also collaborates with
Professor Coates
on a project that bridges physics and
dance and they co teach a course called
the
physics of dance and co-wrote a book
called physics and dance so as you think
so really cool isn't she so as you think
about the journeys you're about to start
tomorrow you cannot have a better guide
than Professor tumors please join me
join me in welcoming her
Thank You Dean Chun and welcome to each
and every one of you I am really
grateful for the chance to pause with
you this afternoon
before starting in with the academic
year that stretches out in front of us
I'm only one of many people at Yale who
cares about you
we're excited about what you bring to
this institution
we're in anticipation of what we'll
learn from you and we have the highest
expectations for what you will gain
while you're you're here and what you'll
take away but no pressure you're here on
purpose you just have to do your best so
what's your plan how are you going to
navigate the resources that surround you
I've been here for about a decade
a decade and two months and I'm still
coming to terms with what we had access
to research tools galleries studios
machine shops libraries it's
overwhelming
say about the experts who populate this
space in our time this afternoon I have
two themes that I want to explore with
you and I'll end with a suggestion the
two themes are balanced and obviously
napkins the suggestion has to do with
your questions and before I get started
I just want to note I'm speaking to you
today as a member of this community as a
faculty member as a physicist I'm not a
Dean I'm not a medical doctor I'm not
currently your professor and I'm one
perspective of many so you should keep
that in mind so how are you going to
choose from our thousands of courses
balance is a reasonable goal how will
you balance your coursework with the
hundreds of extracurricular activities
I'm sure you have already signed up for
how are you gonna balance sustaining
your connections from home while
building your networks here how are you
gonna balance pursuing what you know you
love with discovering what you could
love and this is related but it's a
little different how are you gonna
balance doubling down on what you're
good at
with training yourself in new ways and
becoming an expert in something new how
are you gonna balance your inward focus
on your education and your college time
with an outward focus on our community
in New Haven and beyond will you be
truly advanced above average and
actually get enough sleep consider it
you're worth it as you do your
calculations and make your decisions
balance seems like a reasonable guiding
principle and it's come more and more
into fashion work-life balance that idea
has resulted in important societal
changes positive changes I've spent a
lot of time thinking about balance in a
lot of different contexts and you know
what
I actually think that it can miss the
point
and before I defend that statement let
me introduce some physics you didn't
think you were gonna get away without
some physics okay so what are the
conditions for balance how does a
physical system stay balanced the center
of mass has to be over an area of
support if your center of mass comes out
away from your area of support you start
to fall so what is an area of support
well you take the contact that you're
making with the ground in my case right
now it's my two feet and then it
includes that area of contact with the
area that spans it meaning the rectangle
between my two feet okay so the wider my
stance the bigger my area of support as
I go down to one foot which you can't
see but I promise I'm doing briefly my
area of support is very constrained if I
go up on my toes I have very little room
for my center of mass to wiggle before I
start to fall and let's stick to a
concrete physical system here for a
while my challenge with balance as a
goal you can be balanced under a
tremendous load and you also can be
balancing and exhausted that's why when
people ask me as they frequently do
about my work-life balance I tell them
no I hear that question and I imagine
walking on a tightrope with my work in
one outstretched arm and my life in the
other whatever that means
and I imagine if I'm gonna add a little
more work I have to add a little more
life and the next thing you know you
find yourself at 3 o'clock in the
morning making cookies for your kids
classrooms because you agreed to serve
on a committee for Dean Chun it is the
way of madness
that balance I love those committees I
do but my goal is not to balance as
positive and important as balance can be
my goal is to thrive and that's what I
hope for you here at Yale so how do we
thrive we have to know who we are and
who we want to become we have to know
who we love who loves us we have to
understand what sustains us and what
drains us I want to be centered and I
think that's the point and if it means
that I spend some time balanced then
fantastic when I'm centered I don't have
to remain in my basketball defensive
stance that I learned I actually can go
up on point when I have to and I can
move my center of mass out in front of
my source of support you know what that
is when you move your center of mass out
in front of your source of support it's
called walking you fall and catch
yourself right that's what moving is
it's falling and catching when you're
centered you can do that and I remember
balanced and I suggest thriving over
reacting I have one last comment on that
topic before we move on to napkins which
I know you're waiting for if you want to
be centered you actually have to know
what your Center is you need time to
reflect and the most common mistake we
can make in this context is giving short
shrift to thinking and to sleeping and
you know what that means
that means that you have to turn off
your phone and reflect so now for
napkins
I grew up kindergarten through eighth
grade in a small town in Vermont Groton
Vermont a town of about 600 my father is
a United Methodist pastor he originally
trained as a pianist and my mother
studied
history and education and I'm convinced
that the only job my mother can't do is
the one that she explicitly trained for
she lasted about a day in a middle
school teaching art before she decided
no but she's been a milk tester for
dairy farms she's worked in a nursing
home done hospice care run a Chamber of
Commerce been a telemarketer run a
shelter for victims of domestic violence
run a homeless shelter at etc if there's
a complicated job that doesn't involve
getting 25 students to simultaneously
paint call my mother I didn't grow up in
a wealthy or a formal household and the
goal that I was raised with was not to
do well in the world but to do good as I
was entering high school we moved to the
booming metropolis of Morrisville
Vermont over a thousand people and we
had our own movie theater one screen but
our own theater there were AP classes in
my school advanced placement classes
yeah for college credit and the person
who taught my AP calculus class was my
AP English teacher and we started
calculus with the quote of the day and
I'll never forget that quote of the day
discussions stretching into half of the
course period and getting to the AP test
and not recognizing those curly s things
that some of you may know as integrals
and if you don't know that come talk to
me I'd love to talk to you about
calculus so that didn't go necessarily
well I was an extremely ambitious kid so
I really had run out of classes by the
end of my junior year and as has always
already been confessed I was not as
enlightened as all of you at that point
I applied to Harvard I can get that out
if you have to it was a year early from
a small school that nobody had heard of
I knew that they were need-blind so my
family could afford it
and I had multiple alumni interviews in
an incredible twist of fate
my final alumni interviewer her children
had been my dad's students when he was a
music teacher before going to seminary
she was compassionate and connected and
she knew that I wasn't getting into
Harvard from a school that no one had
heard of a year early with marginal
accomplishments she asked me if I'd ever
considered private school and I told her
it wasn't an option because we couldn't
afford it but she knew about scholarship
opportunities and she set me up with an
interview at Phillips Academy in Andover
and I ended up doing my senior year
there there's one experience in
particular that has stuck with me from
Andover I can't remember why
but I didn't go home for Thanksgiving so
I was invited to the head of schools
house for Thanksgiving and I remember
the room walking in and the dark wood
paneling everywhere but mostly I
remember the place settings I don't know
how you feel about place settings I was
trained on place settings it was one of
my jobs plate in the center fork on the
Left
knife and spoon on the right napkin
folded under the fork okay that's how we
did it when I was growing up this place
setting had multiple knives multiple
spoons multiple forks it had things to
the left of the plate to the right of
the plate and then the indignity of it
stretching on top of the plate moving
away from me
most alarming from my perspective was
the construction on top of my plate it
was a 3d conglomeration that I
recognized as my napkin exactly where
the food is supposed to go I knew I had
to be on point there were rules nobody
was talking about them and I was going
to have to pay attention I looked up
just to see that every napkin was gone
except my own
all napkins missing and it was one of
those moments where you realize
something here is not like the other it
probably only took me a fraction of a
second to see those napkins on people's
laps I remember thinking I do not
understand the you know what is the
purpose what is the utility of the
napkin on the lap since then it saved me
many times from spills but at the time I
thought that was a little bit ridiculous
but I was going with the flow my napkin
went on my lap this idea that there are
rules and it's obvious that there are
rules but no one is talking about them
and you don't know what they are I call
those things napkin moments and I've had
many of them after and over I was
accepted to Harvard I didn't have a lot
of time to figure out a summer job
between high school and going back
before college so I took on two
positions I was a maid at a resort in
Stowe and I was cleaning maintaining
tennis courts which required spreading a
lot of chemicals and it's likely that
exposure to chemicals in one of those
two contexts landed me with an
autoimmune disease so the week that I
was supposed to be at Harvard for
orientation I was having surgery and I
had to miss the year you're well placed
to think about this at Harvard in those
days and maybe it's true I don't know if
it's true here if you miss orientation
you miss the year they say come back in
a year I remember going to orientation
the next year in thinking they have
overestimated how valuable this
experience is
I'm sure you don't feel that way right
now anyway it was ironic the kid who
wants to go to college a year early ends
up going a year late but it gave me the
gift of arriving to college fairly
centered and my napkin moments continued
in college they weren't only social they
were also academic I remember my first
physics classroom at Harvard walking in
and there was a cluster of people it was
a reunion and they were talking about
the physics Olympics and I remember
thinking isn't that cute
physics Olympics like the Olympics
except for physics and I realized oh
that is a real thing
I'm probably in the wrong classroom
right now and it turns out that I was
there was shopping period there as well
I was able to adjust
I took an astronomy class with about a
dozen students and I was the only woman
in the class our professors spent a lot
of time communing with the blackboard
which I understand but he did
occasionally turn around and interact
with us we had a ritual once a week when
he would hand back our homework and he
would read off our names
one at a time Daniel and he would scan
the room and Daniel would raise his hand
James and Jonathan and he would
inevitably get to Sarah my classmates
begged me please don't raise your hand
see what he does will he actually
connect the one female sounding name
with the one female looking person in
the room who has consistently raised her
hand to Sarah but of course I didn't
want to make it any more uncomfortable
in those moments than it already was
scanning the room so I didn't really
pause and it's never been clear to me if
he just was really a warrior of trying
to not see gender he was helping me out
or if he really was that oblivious I
think he might have been the problem
sets in that class were actually my
truth now
in moments I remember reading the
problems and they went something like
this
you have designed and constructed a 250
kilogram rocket and launched it toward
Mars how long will its journey take hint
take into account the rotation of the
earth I'm sure that there was more
information provided but that's about
the level that I was getting and I
remember thinking to myself I'm not just
missing something I think I'm missing
everything and I don't know if you've
had that experience it's interesting
there were rules in lots of different
instances and I didn't know them one
last example from a philosophy class
where there's a very special way to
write a philosophy paper I remember
writing making argument X eight times in
three different ways and getting the
feedback you haven't made argument X in
spite of really dedicated teachers and a
year at Andover I was underprepared and
confused in physics throughout much of
college and there are three things that
I want to acknowledge while we're
together about napkin moments the first
thing to acknowledge is that they really
can be exhausting if you're at a place
that feels like a different planet it's
gonna take some energy anyone who's
lived in a foreign country knows what
this feels like and we have
international students with us here we
have non-traditional students veterans
who are returning to school we have
transfer students we have a lot of
first-generation students many of us are
going to continue to have napkin moments
over the course of this year the second
thing to point out is that they can be
productive if you find yourself
comfortable to the point where you're
not being challenged
make sure you seek out those
opportunities to be productively
uncomfortable I'll give you an example
I am productively uncomfortable when I
co teach physics of dance with professor
Coates and were lined up on one side of
the dance studio and she tells us to
make our way to the other side giving us
some kind of an improvisational prompt
that is terror but productive terror for
me and I encourage you to seek out ways
to be challenged if you haven't done the
last thing that I want to say is to keep
in mind that when you feel the least
equipped and like you least belong those
times might be the very times when you
have the most to give in spite of my
hiccups with the philosophy papers which
were substantial I considered myself a
humanities person physics challenged me
and thrilled me from the moment I
learned about coordinate systems which
is kind of embarrassing to admit but
it's true and it took me many many years
to get to a point where I was thinking
like a physicist now it's really second
nature to me and my other talents and
inclinations have come along for the
ride and it makes me a better physicist
the last thing I want to talk about I
know that it's warm you're all doing
well there's more physics coming the
last thing I want to talk about is your
questions because I have an
organizational principle to suggest for
your time here it's not going to help
you choose your courses or your
extracurricular activities but it might
give you a new way to pay attention and
make the most of the situations you find
yourself in it's not a new idea it
really crystallized for me when I was
reading The Chronicle of Higher
Education do you know about productive
procrastination it's a good one to
figure out
you shouldn't procrastinate but when you
do procrastinate how much better to have
accomplished something you're proud of
in addition to the guilts that you feel
and the problems that you've dug
yourself deeper in so for me I read the
Chronicle of Higher Education to
procrastinate
and in 2013 there was an article by
James Lang that referenced a book about
successful college students written by
Ken Bain what the best college students
do I don't often put much stock in those
kinds of books but Ken Bain wrote a very
insightful book about teaching and what
it is to become a better teacher so I
was optimistic and there were a lot of
good ideas in there the one that stuck
with me is identify your questions and
carry your questions with you everywhere
so what are your questions what is it
that you as an individual wonder about
what do you worry about it could be big
questions questions like how do we
create and maintain justice in a society
or how can I use my privilege to open
doors for others or how do we get the
plastics out of the ocean identify your
most urgent questions and carry them
with you if you are thinking about
justice assume that your math class your
painting course and your time playing
intramural soccer all have something to
contribute it's a way for you to take
responsibility and some level of
direction from education and let you
with your unique skills background
perspective make connections and
discoveries that otherwise wouldn't be
possible like all advice this is
potentially dangerous what I do not mean
by this is for you to walk into your
classes ignore the syllabi and bend the
course to your own will you're at a
research university so your faculty are
theorists and practitioners who are
immersed in our disciplines we bring our
own goals and discipline specific
questions to the table and we're well
informed your own questions are a
supplement they
aren't an excuse to stop listening
they're a motivation to listen well the
assumption with that kind of listening
is that the information is relevant and
you could learn something transformative
and they actually enable you to
contribute in unexpected ways
what I want to do with our remaining
time is walk you through just one of my
questions and share some of what I've
learned by this way of interacting with
the world so here's the question why
does the universe have a speed limit I'm
fascinated by velocity how fast are we
going right now we don't appear to be
moving at all but we're falling around
the Sun at between 50 15 to 20 miles per
second it's very peaceful
if warm we aren't near the center of the
galaxy which is actually for the best
because we think there's a massive black
hole at the center of the galaxy we're
out in the spiral of the Milky Way and
it takes our solar system a few hundred
million miles to complete in orbit that
means that we're moving at about 150
miles per second our galaxy moves
throughout the Local Group of galaxies
and if we think even bigger our universe
appears to be in a period of
accelerating expansion in spite of all
of this relative motion we will not it
seems
find a pair of objects that are moving
faster than the speed of light with
respect to each other our universe has a
speed limit we're gonna dive in one more
step because I'm a particle physicist
and you're Yale students we can do this
thinking about fundamental particles we
have a few examples without mass photons
are particles of light gluons they're
involved in the strong force quantum
chromodynamics
and we theorized gravitons mediators of
gravity
those particles have no mass and by
definition only move at the speed of
light if you have a particle with even a
little bit of mass you can't get that
particle to the speed of light which
means that velocity is intrinsically
tied to mass and the mechanism of mass
discovered in 2012 is the Higgs field
something that I'm studying right now
which ties into my one of my fundamental
questions without the Higgs field
elementary particles would be zooming
around at the speed of light so my
question about the speed limit of the
universe is really linked to the
question of mass in 2012 reasonably soon
after the discovery of the Higgs by my
collaboration and another I was with a
few hundred of my very good friends we
were still celebrating the discovery and
at the back of the auditorium I ran into
a colleague of mine who is a really
talented science communicator I asked
him so how's it going talking about the
Higgs and he said it's hard it's really
difficult to explain in a public setting
you don't pull out quantum mechanics and
field theory and I agreed it was a
challenge for us so I looked for help I
collaborate as you've heard with
professor Emily Coates there was a grant
that was being offered by the New Haven
Council for the Arts to support artists
science scientist teams it was called
reintegrate and it was trying to pull
pairs of artists and scientists together
and that Emily and I were looking for
something to do
associated with it and I asked her can
we tackle the Higgs boson for this in
the process of our work together Emily
went to one of my public lectures on the
Higgs and she asked me after do you have
any idea what you're doing when you're
talking of there you're making all kinds
of motions you're basically dancing the
Higgs as you're up there and I said no I
had no idea and it's problematic to hear
that because I'm gonna be self-conscious
for the rest of my life now talking
about the higgs-boson and she asked me
do you know if your colleagues do this
and I said I have no idea so we set up
to start to interview some of my
colleagues and we collect it we asked
them describe the Higgs and we collected
their analogies and we watched how their
interactions of their bodies actually
mapped to the words they were using in
this process I thought very deeply about
the ways that I was imagining the Higgs
mechanism to work as I talked about it
as I thought about it and noticed the
pieces that weren't safe places where
I'd lifted in macroscopic ideas to
describe a microscopic phenomenon and it
forced me to go back and look more
deeply more deeply more carefully at the
theory it's the people who understand a
concept that are really the best place
to come up with a safe analogy right the
moral of this story for me is that we
shouldn't narrower ourselves prematurely
when it comes to our questions if you
care about getting plastics out of the
ocean
don't take only courses on plastics and
courses on oceans I learned more about
math through working with a
choreographer than I ever could have
imagined I would and I know this may
seem like a selfish way to approach the
liberal arts it's basically looking
around with your questions and thinking
all of these things can teach me about
my stuff but I really think it's the
best compliment you can pay another
discipline to say I believe that you're
relevant to what I care about
and there are insights that can be
offered that are only limited by my
ignorance and I can't even imagine the
connections yet and your stuff and your
questions will change in your time here
I know that you will discover questions
if you're paying attention conversations
with each other inside and outside of
the classroom and I hope and assume that
some of your questions are going to
evolve through your interactions
again with the
other inside and outside of the
classroom I'm gonna free us all soon
because I know we need time to sleep and
time to think just a few more words
balance I think it's a useful framework
but it misses something that I think is
critical I really want you all to thrive
here and that can occasionally require
focus good luck with your napkin moments
you're actually not alone
remember define your questions and carry
them with you everywhere at this point
we're not here for your a compliment
accomplishments we're here for your
potential and one last analogy this
institution is not a fancy Thanksgiving
dinner
and the course catalog is not a menu you
aren't surrounded by assembled dishes
here you're surrounded by ingredients
because you don't consume an education
you have to construct it so turn off
your phone get some sleep
do your best find the help when you need
it and when you can embrace the
challenges you face that train your
brain in productive ways to access the
world in different ways thank you very
much for your time and attention this
afternoon and I really look forward to
seeing you around campus
[Applause]
so professor Demers thank you for that
amazing inspiring words and I hope you
all will will take her advice too
you know as you get to know each other
over the next four years you know share
your napkin moments with each other
share your questions and help each other
find balance you're gonna have a big
reception in your residential colleges
followed by a formal dinner Thanksgiving
like dinner in the dining hall it's
really a memorable event and a great way
to to to spend the evening before your
first day of classes here so I hope you
look forward to that and you all look
really wonderful handsome and lovely and
but before we leave today as promised
you're gonna learn one of our really
most beautiful traditions and so we have
the world-renowned Yale glee club with
us here together
with our most distinguished director
Jeff Dalma who's going to teach you
bright college years so please give a
warm welcome
[Applause]
Thank You Dean Shawn hi everyone good
afternoon as Dean Shawn explained we
conclude the address by inviting all of
you to join in a time-honored Yale
College tradition the singing of our
alma mater bright college years I have a
few members of the Yale Club glee club
here to help me out they're going to
sing through versed one once for you so
you can hear what it sounds like and
after that I will invite all of you to
stand and to sing verses one and two
together as they are printed on the back
of the program it's our tradition at the
end of the second verse to wave our
handkerchiefs in the air so be ready for
that and follow our lead sing out loud
sing out strong and welcome to Yale
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]